I would now like to expand on this idea
that a patient is a point on a reaction
norm by taking apart the
concept of reaction norms
and showing you a bit of what
difference they make to our analysis.
To begin with.
Evolution involves a regular alternation
between genotypes that contained
information and phenotypes
that consists of matter.
This is an important distinction
between information and matter because
different sorts of things
go on in each of them.
A motto from Livan Valence is that
evolution is the control of development by
ecology. And I think is, I stepped through
this. You'll see what van Valan meant.
This picture of which was originally
sketched by Dick Lewington shows a regular
alternation between genotype
space and phenotype space.
So you should think of this as being,
uh,
the universe in which DNA sequences exist.
And this is being the universe in
which organisms exist down here.
Naturally,
they are connected to each other and
they contain each other in some ways.
The first transformation here from g one
to p one from genotype to phenotype is
development. That's transformation
one. And it's at this point,
the genes interact with environments to
map the information in genotypes into
the material in phenotypes.
That's where reaction norms come in.
T two is ecology and behavior.
That's what determines who
survives and reproduces.
T three is mating reproduction and some
of genetics that determines the array of
gametes.
It's going to form the next generation
and then t four is genetics and
reproduction.
That determines how the array of haploid
gametes is transcribed into a set of
deployed zygotes.
This is going on in every generation.
So evolution is operating both in genotype
space and in phenotype space and a
selection is acting on phenotypes.
Development is determining
the expression of phenotypes.
Development is intimately built in to
the apparatus of micro evolution at this
stage.
Now the result of that kind of
developmental transformation
as a reaction norm.
So here is one possible reaction norm.
Here you see temperature and
environmental variable on the x axis.
The value of a trait,
size of maturity on the y axis
and align relating the two things.
So you can say that a
reaction norm expresses the
phenotype is a function of the
environment.
Here you see a depiction of a population.
It consists of a bundle of reaction norms.
Each one of these reaction norms
belongs to a particular genotype,
and the population consists of a set of
genetically heterogeneous individuals,
each one of which had the potential to
produce this value of the trait depending
on the temperature at which it was raised,
and we can calculate a mean reaction
norm for the whole population.
However,
the concept of reaction norm originally
is bound to the concept of genotype.
A genotype has a reaction or
now traits can have markedly
different kinds of of expression.
And one of the earlier lectures we pointed
out that treats have very different
evolutionary ages. They also have very
different phenotypic plasticity. These,
some of them are very insensitive to
environmental change. So for example,
in organisms like us,
the number of digits,
number of fingers or toes
is very insensitive to the
kind of nutrition we have.
We all always end up with five here.
The genotypes of just been
separated by different colors.
Just to show you the different genotypes
are always producing five fingers or
toes no matter what nutritional
environment they're in.
Other traits, for example,
if he come to thee,
are sensitive to changes
in the environment,
so g one in this case is quite
sensitive to changes in nutrition.
When it's well fed, it has many
offspring. When it's poorly fed,
it has few g three is less sensitive,
it has a flat or reaction or so.
That also gets across another concept and
that is that the slope of the reaction
or is a measure of the sensitivity of
that trait to changes in the environment.
Okay.
Because of this differential sensitivity,
genetic correlations can actually change
sign depending on the environment and
when there's a change in the sign of
genetic correlation or covariance across
environments,
then a developmental mechanism is strongly
modulating the expression of genetic
variance and covariance.
That means that the response to selection
is dependent not only on the standing
genetic variance and covariance,
but it's also dependent upon the
way in which it is expressed in.
That can change with environment.
Yeah.
No genetic correlations can
produce indirect selection.
That has surprising effects
in some environment selection
for an increase in one
trait might cause a correlated increase
in another tree and other environments.
Selection for an increase in one trait
may cause a correlated decrease in the
other trade environment's intermediate
to those described selection on one trait
won't be correlated with any
response in the other at all. So
reaction are important modulators of
selection responses and that becomes
especially important when we're trying
to evaluate the effects of tradeoffs.
Okay.
Here for example,
is a detailed experiment that was done
under Sophala marketure him by Martin gay
part.
He studied AGD closing and waited,
he closure and he raised basically
sets of families derived from two females.
Now the nice thing about these females
of soflar Mercato forum is that if you
don't give them males to mate with,
they will still produce viable
offspring and they will do it asexually.
So each of the small envelopes down
here consists of a group of identical
siblings from one mother and
this is from the other mothers.
So you have six groups of identical
siblings from one mother in six groups of
identical siblings from another mother
raised out across different yeast
concentrations, which allows for a
precise measurement of reaction norms.
Okay.
Martin observed a positive
genetic correlation when
the flies were well fed and
growing rapidly.
That's this 1.5% yeast concentration here.
And you can see that the slope of
this line is steep and positive and he
observed a negative genetic correlation
when they were poorly fed and growing
slowly.
And the slope of this line is negative.
So this is a shift in genetic correlation
between two traits driven by variation
in the nutritional environment.
Yeah.
And that is an experimental confirmation
of the idea that reaction norms are
modulating the expression of genetic,
not only of genetic variation,
but if genetic covariation
in the phenotype.
Okay.
Now what are the consequences of
plasticity for genetic definitions of
tradeoffs?
Well,
genetic correlations among traits can
change from population to population
within populations over time as gene
frequencies change during the course of
development and from
environment to environment.
The responses to selection that are
then important for life history.
And can also change and all the same ways.
Yeah.
This is not just about fruit flies
living on yeast in test tubes in the
laboratory.
This is also about things like the
demographic transition in the industrial
revolution,
which has changed the whole landscape
of selection operating on contemporary
human beings.
There are important consequences of
plasticity for the human response to
selection to these recent important
changes in our environments.
Yeah,
I love this picture because it is such
a dramatic and easily understandable
depiction of what a difference human,
uh, developmental makes the human.
So auto and evolved spits are identical
twins. They have the same genomes.
At the age of 18,
auto began to run distance and Aviall
began to lift weights and four years later
at the age of 22,
this is what they look like.
This is how large a difference can result
in the human phenotype due to simple
differences in lifestyle,
culture,
and environment that have
nothing to do with genotype. Now,
what is the medical significance
of phenotypic plasticity?
One of the areas in which
that significance is
particularly striking is the
developmental origins
of health and disease.
This has been a rapidly growing area,
which now has its own acronym Dohad that
indicates that things that happen early
in life have important
consequences later in life.
Thin infants are at increased risk
of cardiovascular disease, diabetes,
and obesity in late life.
We have learned that exposure
to starvation conditions
either in utero or very
early after birth,
will increase risk of these
diseases 50 or 60 years later.
Infants that are born by c section or
at increased risk of [inaudible] and
obesity.
Children who have antibiotic treatments
before age two are at greater risk of
obesity and allergies.
These are effects mediated by Microbiota.
So these are all reaction norms.
These are responses of genotypes
to variation in the environment.
Phenotypic plasticity
can be of several types.
It can be reversible so of body
weight and muscle mass are reversible.
Auto and evolved spits probably could
have reversed the way they appear by
switching, uh, regimes.
It can be irreversible.
Body height does not change after
maturation and humans very much.
It can be confined to specific
developmental stages. So, for example,
the whole Dohad paradigm tells us that
things that happen early in life in
particular, probably in, uh,
in utero and in childhood are critical
and can have knock on consequences
throughout life.
Some of them can be produced at any stage.
So tanning and acclimation to altitude
can be produced at any stage of
development.
Some of them are continuous,
like agent maturation and others
are discontinuous. So for example,
you can have morphs in water fleas,
cast in insects where
they're morphologically quite
distinct things that are
being produced by the same genotype.
And in summary,
the expression and development of many
traits are sensitive to the environment.
The concept of a reaction norm is useful
analyzing how genes and environments
interact to produce phenotypes.
Reaction norms are properties
of genotypes, and then humans,
they are most clearly visualized as
the differences that develop between
identical twins,
reared in different environments or
undergoing different exercise regimes.
Many medical conditions in adults are
sensitive to environments and countered
early in life.
That's the doe had paradigm.